there's a whole other set of issues
about how robots should be treated under
the law now the obvious knee-jerk
reaction is well you want a robot you're
responsible for everything that it does
but as these devices become much more
autonomous it's not at all clear that
that's really the right answer or a good
answer
you go out and you buy a great new robot
and you send it down the street to go
pick you up a Frappuccino down at
Starbucks and maybe it's accidental but
it's standing on the corner it happens
to bump some kid into traffic and a car
runs the kid over the police come
they're gonna come arrest you for this
action do you really feel that you're as
responsible as you would be if you had
gone like this and push that kid into
traffic I would argue no you don't so
we're going to need new kinds of laws
that deal with the consequences of
well-intentioned autonomous actions that
robots take now interestingly enough
there's a number of historical
precedents for this you might say well
how can you hold a robot responsible for
its behavior you really can actually and
let me point out a couple of things the
first is most people don't realize that
corporations can commit criminal acts
independent of the people in the
corporation so in the Deepwater Horizon
Gulf Coast accident as an example BP oil
was charged with criminal violations
even though people in the corporation
were not necessarily charged with those
same criminal violations and rightfully
so so how do we punish the corporation
you punish a corporation by interfering
with its ability to achieve its stated
goal you make huge fines as they did in
that particular case you can put you can
mint the company go out of business you
can revoke its license to operate which
is a death penalty for a corporation
you can have it monitored as they do in
antitrust cases many companies IBM
Microsoft I think have monitors to
sure they're abiding by certain kinds of
behavioral standards well that same kind
of activity can apply to a robot you
don't have to put a robot in jail but
you can interfere with what it's it's
trying to do and if these robots are
adaptable logical and learning they'll
say well I get it
you know I can't do that because my goal
is to accomplish something in particular
and if I take this particular action
that's actually going to be working
against my interest in accomplishing
that situation
Sohrab ILIT rehabilitation and
modification of robot behavior just as
with the corporation is much more
logical than you might think
now another interesting historical
precedent is prior to the Civil War
there were a separate set of laws that
applied to slaves they were called the
slave codes and slaves were property but
interestingly enough the slave owners
were only held liable under certain
conditions for the actions of their
slaves the slaves themselves were
punished under if they committed crimes
and so we have a historical precedent
for the kinds of ways in which we can
sort this out so that you are not in
constant fear that your robot is gonna
bump into somebody and you're gonna go
to jail for 20 years for negligent
homicide or whatever it might be